par-delà cette frontière la biélorussie
les troupes et l'a retiré russes sont à
50 kilomètres à peine pourtant ces
gardes frontières d'ukrainiens gardent
leur calme déjà des prêts coordonnés ce
touch bayiha bolivie réserve et qui aura
zine
écologie terme de peter jackson dans nos
colonnes jusqu'à présent malgré la
menace russe les gardes frontières n'ont
pas relevés leurs niveaux d'alerté
images de leurs drones envoyé en
reconnaissance les rassure la quasi
totalité de cette frontière est couverte
de forêts et de marécages
un terrain que les tanks comme celui ci
un trophée ramené du dombass est offert
au musée militaire de tchernihiv auront
du mal à traverser
la côte à côte les civils
originaires du dombass dont il a fui les
bombardements en 2014 mireille l'ogive
aux rough prend pourtant la menace russe
très au sérieux
tout comme les autorités municipales qui
l ont pris les devants
et pousse timothy d'iéna au club ligne
aux promotions
pour l'heure à tchernobyl la vie suit
son cours seul indice alarmant les
indications des abris bombes ont été
repeints panier spasov de kruth voici
une partie de ses lignes d'avenir
amis aux trois départements
sauf
les abris au sein des institutions
publiques eux sont mieux équipées comme
dans cette maternité petit frère et
chimu pour costa
alors casta doug reinhardt crying
machettes sont pas du même service et a
signé nombre de touristes des luttes
ici il y a déjà des pelles et des
pioches pour creuser à travers les
décombres